welcome to this video this new video
will be a cubed Singh video I hope um
I'll get some games not just one or two
of Hikaru Nakamura here playing five
minutes on the ICC and this game is
running against um I think it's no
vision right Magnus should know Denmark
oh I'm sorry some fille de marsay from
Denmark and but the flags are pretty
pretty little here okay from Denmark if
you if you believe those flags because
you can set them freely now now come
we're all so it's got the the flakier of
the United Kingdom I'm not quite sure if
he's some spending some time there or if
there's some some other reason behind
this all right okay let's have a look at
the game um yeah actually think that the
field master here the black player isn't
so so well of oh no II five yeah maybe
you should just roped xe5 I would have
preferred yeah very a messy position
okay so i have three this looks just
looks difficult for white oh now there's
Queen f7 coming check we have seven and
Queen f6 yeah frankly speaking um I mean
I'm sometimes playing too slow but
slowly but why didn't like think for a
bit of let it let's just for a couple of
seconds I mean I cannot believe okay
white is now completely winning a look
up for for for nothing black resigns but
yeah that's let sit for instance in this
position let's just think about a bit at
least I mean how how can you how can she
play this this instantly there's
probably a rookie six or
no it isn't so clear this position
probably I mean if he may be saw Knight
f3 and Quincy four and then but then
Queen f7 and well this is just winning
for white but maybe you can can
alternate moves here and move like rook
f8 yeah probably i don't know maybe Luke
f8 is also not not not without its
points just attacking f32 times and
going on f2 i mean i don't know i don't
know maybe it is bed anyway but this was
just to quickly play them in two minutes
or so it's quite quite a bit of time of
course no cameras time spent is insane
like one and a half minute for this and
black was certainly certainly are right
around this point don't turn think okay
so a new game and why does some
grandmaster let's check quickly key
lunch huh Schneider who blew a
grandmaster don't didn't know this
player ok and a camera played here a 6b
five though I think it's called the st.
George defense if i'm not mistaken of
famous some form being used by English
grandmaster Tony miles to beat the then
world champion ought to be capped off in
nineteen eighty and it's of course fun
to beat the world champion with 1a6 what
people are always for failed to mention
is that Kappa was completely winning and
and just just blundered big blunder to
lose the game so okay but while miles
had the laughs on his side of course
winning with a six ok so I'm a very
close position here no lines open at all
what black babies trying to do and
probably successfully and to win the a
forum on because this is just an
isolated pawn in a way it is a complete
unsupported by any piece and it cannot
be covered in any way okay first I'm
black is making a couple of moves yonder
on the kingside white has nice nights on
a g5 and f4 black has no pawn moves like
he can only can never play f6 and this
position basically the only plan for
blankets what I mentioned to try to grab
the e4 pawn my guess is that he's
playing Bishop to d7 and night around to
be six but not sure this is what I would
do but then of course the camera is a
much better player so you know you never
know yeah i'm not sure what he's doing
but probably not much okay if you put
the bishop first on yet but now I think
the night will go to be 6e m4c okay I
had some some right idea and a four
point before then King a six-night b6
back and then you try to play a
four-night to be five and a three why
does not doing much I mean I don't
understand what he's doing what you
should at least try to do something like
playing g4 at some point this is just
like getting slaughtered I mean if you
play King g2h to black will get the
night to be five and play a three and
this was rather obvious i'm not sure why
never he played king g2h to now for 20
moves and why didn't he try and book
somewhere i roped g 1 and g 4 of course
they're probably it is bad because you
have this bishop on b1 which is a dead
piece it can never move and therefore
probably it was bad for white anyway but
yes so moving the King all the time is
not then then you can also resign
frankly speaking
and now it's doing it yam c3 is also a
very big porn now it will feel formed
for for pretty quickly yeah I think
right now probably check yeah just takes
on c3 and resins white resins yeah very
weird game I think by white I mean he
probably was bad anyway due to the bad
bishop on them we adjust the board a bit
led you to the dead bishop won't be one
but still planking g2h to all the time
until you're busted on the queenside is
weird okay we have some strange some
Scandinavian sent a counter set up the
cameras opponent years and i am from
from the United Kingdom it's known name
in them so no idea who that is it's not
so hydrated with 2200 I'm turn the
camera also with two sixes some a bit
below his his best ratings I mean you
know he was on two thousand eight
hundred and so on yeah I think I'm Susan
announce me I need to switch that off
right hey yeah i think i'm white should
be m should be pretty pretty good in
this position simply we call some
what I need to switch off the other game
this is irritating um yeah why should be
in pretty good shape here because he's
got a very solid porn cover here with
the fianchetto bishop and the pods
around the king and black while he's not
in immediate danger with this king this
is a bit airy this distinct position
when Tom I think white will gain some
meditating taking chances in the long
run yeah but now night to d3 i'm not
sure why didn't why did you place he
form
probably f5 now and I known f5 and now
you can take on beach one day three what
instantly on a three is also not bad
this looks rather shaky now and I know
c4 was C for a three oz as usual on very
very quickly played by my camera but
it's probably not not so great white
really disheartened yeah I guess it was
pretty much disgusted with this position
and just resigned now I think the
problem is the rookie is hanging and if
you if you retreated let's say here I
don't know they did you get to keep
distance peace then then this is me was
coming and there's no way to to pretend
to protect be three this doesn't help
black will probably I'm a door or when
when lots of material he had this this
is this is winning yeah Nettie also I
quit he quit the server unfortunately he
very often does that after loss which is
um yeah I don't know it sometimes seems
a bit bit bit strange but it's sometimes
not a bad idea at least after losing a
game to UM yet to just take a small
break and refresh yourself and then play
only after a couple of minutes when you
feel yeah fresh again this is sometimes
a good idea I will I will check reef
Leah from oops if there is some other
interesting num games to watch and so
yeah a lot so not many not many high
rated players to watch actually yeah
there's just nothing I mean there there
are a couple of games played but it's
nothing it's nothing special that I I
would like to very often I don't even
know I know the players yeah all right
if maybe i will i will get a
notification anyway if nakamura return
so i'll try to get some games masonic
okay so let's play a couple of games
myself now zone 3 minute game against
them i am from this Giri I yet I knew it
was some African countries as always if
like guessing you hit ok so I'm the
London system um black has multiple
options again this opening I'm going
here for very classical set up with
Bishop to b6 which I am recently looked
at and then a book my recent new book by
an Israeli grandmaster Borges a froakie
m recommended this setup but I honestly
I forgot how how it is continued mmm
yeah Quincy 70 Queen e7 mini I don't
know but then it looks like I'm losing a
tempo if he if he takes the Sun also
should be am fairly a solid
one idea is sound from black
indisposition some to play Queen c7 and
now I don't even need to be liquid c7
what I was getting at is the maneuver
knight c6 c7 to f5 and then probably m21
to e4 ok let's prepare this night f5d
634 yeah yeah this looks uh looks
comfortable now I have two nights for
one square so I exchange off one of the
nights it should be a good idea and now
I'm trying for Bishop a6 getting rid of
them them yeah yeah this is interesting
now but probably probably i don't play a
5 I don't really need it ok he secured
this this Bishop for a moment the
question should i play a 5 and 94 it's
um it's it's good for black anyway I
mean the question is what is the best
way to to play the problem is that the
his Bishop is constantly bad on c1 well
my bishop on a sixsome has got some
ideas
my idea is to take on b5 and then play
Bishop c4 and now we can do it if a 3
was really we had moved the ID laws but
should be three getting rid of this
bishop and then I would have the great
knight on e4 against this very bad
bishop okay so let's go ahead here
should I play see form interesting
question I should now I mean I don't
need to do it at the moment let's just
activate the Queen the only idea that
white has is of course g4 I mean this is
really the only kind of activity that
white can can go for and I think my next
move phone I can't think about Queen d3
actually Queen d3 to see to the night is
some just a monster piece covering d to
f 2 and so on so I'm not quite sure how
I even have protects me to now yeah he
doesn't protect it yeah should I take it
I'm sure it takes e4 pawn business is
simpler let's just make sure that I keep
the the great night yeah just here I
don't know me too and this is 90 tool
might resign I resigned before I could
could play that yeah this look down
pretty a pretty nice yeah this is the
solid to solid set up against whites
whites London system it's not the only
one I described a couple in in my in my
video serious then I did a couple of I
don't know round two month ago unlocked
not sure I'm against the London but this
is also a good one started okay I'm
let's go fo for change I've got Dwight
here against the Turkish I am and let's
play the bishops opening for for change
didn't do that offline all yeah with the
night f3 white kutum transpose back to
the Italian game that this now is some
really more like a beginner with Knight
c3 and time f4 ok he ok he didn't play d
6 which irritated me slightly uh huh
interesting didn't know that this kind
of stuff was possible yeah i don't i
don't really know the opening i must
admit okay rook f1 he maybe has gotten I
takes hmm so maybe I should should i
move the Queen yeah maybe too so that
all night f12 Godric f 1 i'm not sure
bishop to check yeah if this if this is
helpful for what I don't know should I
go here I'm not sure ok King to a d1
also wasn't wasn't without its points of
this i don't understand was in g for
just hanging wait just wait okay i need
to take it yeah this is this is clear
and now okay if I take g4 he would
probably play d 5 but g5 bishop age 6 I
mean takes you 5 f-5 takes on c4 yeah I
don't know all this looks look strange
to me ok the problem is the time I'm
what is playing miss probably complete
nonsense it's been it's a
still a matter of time yeah okay I can
can win the exchange now but it's not
not clear if this helps oh to be
probably I should I should take it I've
got them of course I'm a very
questionable King position this is clear
let's flip bring the night over to g3
you can take on me to it it's just a
pawn want to activate pieces here yeah
this is typical for 43 minutes chess
where they even though complete nonsense
it's not so easy to reviewed at least
for me I mean in some I'm not very am
good three-minute Flair don't don't play
this time solve this is also simply I'm
a problem if you don't don't place on
time control too often you really have
eddie's this applies to me I have
problems finding the right kind of speed
for for this
trying to isolate the g5 pawn can cover
it with night what what what what what's
happening on this move now king a king
of our cake England's probably but this
is a very shaky phone for black
time morning and maybe I should have
played 95 instantly the problem here is
just the time and of course adds very
tricky cause and now d3n time I'm
probably the Quincy phone is checked
cheat me yeah it's just I ever was
problems adjusting to to this time um
cause I'm am well that let's just forget
about this game always a bit frustrating
people play complete complete nonsense
and you you're still told win I mean
this is just just just nonsense I'm
probably I can play all kinds of stuff
here might be five armed whatever very
hard to believe that this should be it
should be any good attacking with three
pieces and yes not even move the jeep on
I mean yeah yeah Queen f6 was
interesting maybe maybe better well
maybe 95 I don't know it is complicated
this is actually five minute game and
you to readjust again neither three okay
let's play let's play something like g6
staying flexible yeah yeah probably you
get some some sort of English opening or
maybe t44 Kings Indian Union hard to
tell it's not committing the deep on
okay so we've got a pure pure English
age 6 is to prevent on Bishop g5 which
isn't so terrible in the first place but
it's not another bad move to play like
this okay I place the six trying to to
blunt the bishop yeah come on let's play
d5 okay so he's some trying to put some
pressure on the center and down maybe
this isn't too bad okay play rookie a to
prepare to recapture with the with the
night okay rook a one now oh and of
course played instantly okay maybe I can
go to d4 here I played d for now what is
he doing then he captures 94 this must
be okay otherwise I'd take on e3 ok
let's play d4 don't dung waste more time
hmm yeah this all looks very very weird
putting the Queen on the long diagonal
is certainly a strange strange decision
but that's not clear that i can now
immediately benefit from that ok i don't
want to spend so much time sometimes you
have those games where the opponent will
play moves instantly whether they make
sense or not and then you if you spend
too much time your problem you have a
good position but you will win on time
and some silly fashion so let's just
play on play a bit quicker yah 95
a question he didn't look at all ready
for which is of course an idea before
opening the long diagonal I come on I'll
play this yeah of course instantly it's
so easy this game he was attacking the
Queen so I couldn't take a plane idea
three but he will take take on da doll
so but now I have this threat of Knight
f3 okay I could I could play Knight f3
now winningham at least the exchange
yeah I should do that I think and the
nidus of course on not too badly placed
on a three it's always this made on h2
that you hit you want to want to get
into okay he's also having now the rook
here on free is not protected and on a
three this Bishop is also um bit fragile
maybe this is a good idea attacking the
rook covering the the night additionally
and I don't know I really where he is
going now yeah you know I can take here
Queen f3 rookie one just just rinse the
house and rookie one is coming I mean
this is this is now right resigns yeah
it's no wonder if he play instantly in
computing can complex positions you will
lose at least I hope that this route
leads to some losses I mean how can you
I don't understand you spent two seconds
on this move I mean isn't this a
complicated position I would think so ok
let's try
I 4k just was great okay a three-minute
again maybe I should really stick to
five okay I'm a black against crap a
blank am I let's play the CARICOM play
from Canada list with them canadian flag
we've got the exchange Carol come on yet
the line well um yeah um like shouldn't
have any particular problems but it's of
course unplayable option for white 93
mmm yeah I don't not be five firm can be
can be a bit of an annoying move okay
let's play if I first I mean I want to
go e five anyway and now i have half
this a six possibility ok money goes to
deform yeah okay probably I should have
just done just played a six like I
wanted to in the first place it's a of
coordinated it always amazes me people
j/k just instantly all the time but yeah
maybe I'm just too bad for this game
okay cannot take on g7 anyway king of a
tender strapped
quite resigned what hmm yeah i'm a bit
of a bit shocked here I'm trying to
figure out why I played 25 I mean this
is not even a mouse live maybe it
touched the g five pawns as possible if
you have a smart move in and you click
on v5 a place night queen txt file ok
yeah whatever if it'll be lucky once in
a while with game game start it down ok
let's play one more three minute and
then call it a holiday so Queens gambit
I could play the Catalan ok let's play
the kettle on and played this for 1g
yeah this is some quite a quite a good
line for black and of course I
completely forgot how to how to play
this I think this is a viable option to
special poem you'll want to get c4 back
yeah the question is I take on your take
on see fried eggs on d4 yeah probably
well yeah hope you I need to play this
it's not not brilliant he can just apply
97 and black is quite okay yeah maybe 98
as well ok I want to get rid of this
Bishop questions some okay well not be
sick so i can probably take all right
maybe I can play a night huh and so I
didn't really think about that before
the a problem come on we will push the
porn all the way to to a b6 with the
idea of playing I'd be five also
yeah no no I'm attacking v6 and don't
know how to replace yeah then i can i
can take here or play d6 not sure and
check here and then d6 a group text c5
md6 butch xe5 phone we can take on b6
unfortunately okay probably this is
right cannot really calculate yeah 3
minute is really just just like a bullet
game almost and just a little bit of
more time to once in awhile think i'm a
bit a bit more deeply but really now i
see i can now see what i can do i can
probably young n not now is in an
opinion and then g710 oops didn't think
about that at all
ah the time the time yeah this is
probably in some way winning for white
but 20 seconds i played this because I'm
look c 8f g7 and um qalam threatening
roxy five you cannot move the night
because it is hanging can check you can
proceed in this way and then with 37
coming I don't see a move for black it's
probably probably good now you know it I
cannot move the night time morning still
I cannot move it check check check check
14 feet so much
no comment yeah I'm just just just too
slow i mean the system easy this and he
was he was rather quick when I was just
too slow I mean okay just I should just
switch to five minute and be done with
it but I mean them yeah okay all right i
hope you enjoyed the video anyway
despite my my ranting about me playing
too slowly yeah i hope you enjoyed it
till next time bye